(J) - Too bad for you! (B) - Hey, hey I'm gonna win!
(B) - I've got a really good hand, I'm gonna win.
(M) - ME TOO!
(W) - Bob's, uhh... -_-
(J) I don't know what the Fuck I'm doing
(J) - Who's first? Uh, Bob's first. (B) - Uhhh...
(M) - YES! Heh, c'mon Bob! Oh. (W) - WOW! Screwin' Mark from the start!
(M) - That's a little... I don't- (W) - Pick a color, there you go! (M) - Ughhh.
(B) - WHY DID I PICK- That's not what I wanted! (Group laughs)
(B) - I tried to click on a different one!
(M) - Wait why does that say "Challenge or decline"? What happens if I ch-
(W) - Be- because if you think you can play one then- (Bob laughs)
(M) - Oh... (Mark laughs) WHOOPS!
(B) - Plus six cards!? (Bob laughs) (M) - GODDAMMIT!
(J) - What happened? (W) - Mark challenged Bob's "Plus Four" thinking he had a green and lost, so Mark had to Draw- what (Bob wheezes)
(Bob hysterically laughs) (W) - Are you shitting me, WHY BLUE?!
(M) - I didn't- I tried to- (W) - GOD!!! (Bob and Jack laugh)
(M) - Wha- I tried to do something- What the fuck is this game?!
(W) - You got Uno, why- (B) - Wow, you fucking suck (Mark groans)
(J) - It's Uno, bro! (M) - Well this is- this is a bunch of bullshit!
(W) - Now you skipped Jack! (M) - HUH - HAH (Bob laughs)
(W) - I will- (J) - FUCK! (W) -... Skip Bob!
(M) - This game is such- (Jack laughs) Uhh, I will skip Jack!
(J) - FUCK YOU! (Bob and Mark laugh)
(W) - I will-! Take Jack's hand!
*Whoosh noise from the game*
(B) - Ohh! I forgot about that shit (J) - WHAT!?
(M) - Oh yeah! (B) - I will, take Wade's hand! (W) - Oh, god!
(Mark laughs) (W) - NOOO!
(Mark laughs louder) (J) - Okay, this is a different Uno that I'm used to!
(M) - I will, take Bo- take of- what the f*ck does that mean?! (Wade and Jack chuckle)
(W) - Click an arrow! (M) - Ohh, okay, alright! I didn't know I had to pick!
(W) - Oh my god (M) - Fuck
(J) - Uhh, I will- (W) - Ja- Jack can play a 7 and take it back. (M) - JESUS CHRIST! (Jack, Wade and Bob laugh)
(M) - the FUCK IS THIS?!?
(W) - Well, I- (Mark, Jack and Bob laugh
(M) - NOT MY HAND! (J) - Come the fuck on! (Wade laughs)
(B) - Ohhh, criminy. (W) - Oh my god. (M) - Oh, boy.
(J) - Please play a 7.
(B) - I don't- I don't have one. (J) - You have three seconds.
(M) - Go! (B) - I would play a 7, I want to- (W) - Oh, my turn!
(M) - HE'S GONNA PLAY A S- Oh, I thought he was gonna play that 7 I had.
*Blinging noises from the game* (J) - Oh, fuck you.
(Mark chuckles) (W) - It was the only green I had...
(J) - What a fuckin'- (M) - Uhhhhhh... (Continuous) (B) - Hey, welcome to "Last", Jack it's the best! (M) - BAP!
(M) - HUH, A NORMAL CARD! Bet 'ya didn't expect that! (B) - Wow...
(J) - Wh- Wha- What's "Jump in"?
(W) - Press "8"- if you have a green 8 you can press it and "Jump in", or you click on it.
(J) - Agh, fuckin' tits, I didn't know that... (M) - Yeah, I, tried to do that, didn't work.
(W) - Well that's alright, here I'll give you another chance.
(Bob chuckles) (B) - Dick.
(B, Pathetic Scottish accent) NAT BLUE!
(W) - I had to draw it! It's not like I wanted to!
(J) Uhhh, I dunno what- "Challenge or Decline"- (M) - JACK CHALLENGE IT (x4)
(J) - AHGH, I didn't, I declined! (M) - CHALLNGE- (W) - Probably for the best, you would have lost.
(M) - Fucking loser! Loooser, Looser!
(W) - YOU WATCHED ME DRAW THOSE CARDS!
(M) - I got- (J) - I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING. I went from first to last- very quick! (Bob laughs)
(M) - Why am I drawing so many cards! (Bob screams/laughs) (J) - Mark- Mark- (M) - GODDAMMIT
(Wade, Jack and Bob laugh)
(M) - FUUCK! (W) - I'm screwed because I can't-
(B) - Oh ho, my god! (M) - Ugh, fuck! Oh, no...
(B) - Oh, fuck. (M) - This game is garbage!
(W) - I don't- wanna- (Mark imitating Wade) - I DON'T  WANNA! WHAT DON'T 'CHA WANNA DO? WIN?!
(W) - I've got it- somebody's gonna get this hand from me!
(W) - I can't keep it, 'cause I've got bad cards... (J) - There we go! F*ckin'... Doobie cards, bitches! (M) - No, I can't!
(J) - Hey, there ya' go! You did it!
(Bob sighs) (J) - Thank you, buddy. (B) - Fuck.
(J) - Wade's gonna win. (W) - No, I can't! I cannot win. (B) - I've got this, don't worry, I've got this.
(Mark making fun of Wade) - HE CANNOT WIN GUYS IT'S IMPOSSIBLE, HE CAN'T WIN!
(B) - Oh, sorry Jack. Play a draw two, Jack, you can do it!
(W) - YEAH! Mark's gonna draw 6! (Jack laughs) (M) - No I'm not! (J)- STEAMROLLED!
(J) Oh no! (M) Fuck me... HEY! Heh HEH HA!(J)- STEAMROLLED! (Mark starts laughing)
(B) - Alright well- (M) - HEH HUE HEH HAH!
(Jack starts laughing) (W) Oh, no! (J) This is fun!
(M) - Oh yeah, OH! (B) - Nice! (W) - NO! NO! NO!!! (Bob laughs)
(J) - Keep it goin'!
(B) - I like how quickly everyone's opinion shifts- (M) - AH HAH! (B) - Like, "THIS FUCKING SU- Oh hey, this is fun!"
(Jack groans)
(J) - Skipped 'ya right over, Jack! Skipped 'ya right over. Should have jumped in quicker- (J) - WHAT A DICKO!
(M) - Should have jumped in!
(B) - You know what, though? (Jack laughs) (M) - OH NO!
(M) - Fuck you, Bob! (Jack chuckles and Bob laughs)
(W) - Teehee.
(M) - HA HA! (B) - No! (M) - Eat sh*t, Bob!
(B) - Actually, that was only a 1 card upgrade for you.
(W) - I know! (B) It was kind of a waste. (Bob laughs)
(W) - Oh! (B) - Ah... Aye... (M) - Nailed it!
(J) - Got 'em!
(M) - F*ck.
(J) Did I do good?
(Wade laughs) (M) Aaah shit. (B) Maybe
(M) Challenge
(B) Please tell me he decided whether to challenge...Nope
(W) Oh wow! (M) Yay!! (B) Ohhhhh
(M) OH EAT SHIT EAT SHIT!! (B) Oh wow!
(M) I don't know what the f*ck happened (J) I don't get it
(M) I don't either (J) Yeah what does that do?
(W) Because you could play a red card he challenged it and won.
(J) Challenge how, what? What did he challenge?
(B) Jack if you try to play a card that is not a Wild then (and) you play a Wild he challenges you then you lose the challenge and you draw the cards.
(B) So you had a card you could have  played  a side from the Wild. (M) Haha! Eat Shit.
(J) Ohh! oh ok. (B)  The fuck why is it back to me. (M) Cause I jumped in.
(W) Cause Mark jumped in. (M) Cause I jumped in.
(B) Oh! well then that fucking sucked. (M) Haha!
(B) Alright well. (J) Man Uno is fucking savage. (M) and (W) Yeah.
(M) Fucking wow
(W) That's like the first normal card that I got to play in a while
(W) Oh!
(M) Oh!
(J) haha!
(M) NO!  (B) Thank God, Thank God geez. (Jack Laughing)
(W) No No  don't. NOOOO! (Bob laughs) Oh thank god.
(B) No! oh ok. (M) BOOOO!
(B) BOOOO!
(J) -per Dooper!
(W) I gotta run for a second
(M) Yeah you do
(J) Do your turns quick! Do your turns Quick
(Bob laughs) (B) Yeah do it quick! Do it quick! Do it quick! Team up against Wade.
(J) That's just Depressing (Mark Giggling) Good job Bob.
(W) YOU SKIPPED ME! (Mark, Jack And Bob Laughing)
(J) Wade.
(W) A- holes
W: Blue and yellow are not the colors guys please
J: Yeah M: Yeah
B: Blue and yellow are cool man
M: They seem good to me W: Oh my god J: what have you got against-  W: NO! NOO!
Everyone: B and J: yes! yES! M: Cute giggles
B: drAW CARDS... agh J:  NOO!
M: Ahhhh fuckin J: Hey Wade, have I ever told you the story about Darth Plagueis the Wise....?
W: No?! What's the story? B: Oh god jeez okay well (nice phrasing bobby boy)
J: It's a story the Jedi would not tell you ;) W: Oh tell me!
B: Jee.. I wonder what he's gonna do..
J: *giggles* ahhhhh titty tittY tittieS! Uuummm this one!
B: Oh nOO!
W: no no no. no, after you! M: *laughs*
J: Oh shit tits.. uh sorry sir after YOU! W: *laughs*
M and B : *continuous laughter*
W: Well if you INSIST I guess I'll play.
M: hAHA J: You sprung my trap card!
B: nO NO MARK WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT TO ME?!?!?!
M: Ah! Because I hate you that's why! W: noOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!!!
M and J: *laugh* B: Alright I got a plan, I got a plan bois.
W: oh nO.. nOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!! B: Yay! M: Oh interesting interesting interesting...! J: whAT??!?
W: Zero's make us all rotate our hands.
M: ho HO! I don't know what I did, I jumped in myself.
B: What the fuck?!?
M: I jumped in myself! B: how what is that a thing? J: yeah, yeah.
W: Yeah you can jump in and do it if you have the same card.
M: *indescribable sound*
W: Oh god...
B: How about this colour? W: This is terrible.. M: I can'T DO THAT COLOUR
M: Oh wait, y-yeah, yes I can! There we go!  W: Oh god.
B: Alright I have a serious problem now.. I have a serious problem with this hand! J: Do it again!
M: FUCK YOU MAN I WAS GONNA DO THAT.... Oh there we go. W and J: *laugh*
J: I'm still losing though! Fuck!
W: No don't jump in make Bob play his card! B: Oh fuck sake M: Wait hang on.
M: I gotta draw cards again you, fuckin' assshole J: It's just you and me buddy!
M: fuck you! fuck you! fuck you! Take some of THIS! Everyone else: *laugh*
W: OHHHHHHH B: Aw SHIT! FUCK
M: Fuckin... BooooB. I don't know.
B: Oh wow really? W: WhY'D YOU MAKE IT THE SAME COLOUR???!!?
B: *laughs* J: You just made it yellow again! M: I don't know. I just felt like it.
B: Oh god... alright, well that's cool.. that's fine I guess. W: Oh my god.
B: hAHAA. WOO!
W: nOOOOO! M: *giggle*
W: bleU!
J: Yeaaahhhhh... that works.
W: Yeah! M: Uhhhhh boopa da doop
M: Jumpa da in.. B: Oh. W: Hey!
B: Fuck's sake. J: Heh, jump in on self!
B: I hate all of you
M: heh, yump myseeelf W: yaaaay
B: oh come on... oh come ON OH NO COME ON
B: NO DON'T DO IT LIKE THAT NO, OH  YEAH TAKE THAT GUYS NO FUCK YOU W: OH NOOOOOO!!
J: Noo!!!  M and B: *laughs* W: No god Whyyyyyyyy.
B: haHAha W: Wait! I'll do it again
J: nOOOOOO All: *laughing*
J: NNOOOOOO B: Everything's coming up good for Bob, man. Damn.
J: Ohh, you guys can suck the inside of my rectum. W: *dying*
M: Uhh...I'd rather not W: Yeah, you could have played another zero.
M: HEEey! I'll draw.
J: Aw, shit.  W: You had another zero, Jack. M: Yes!
J: Fuck, man. M: Haba-omnom
B: Ah, I got one of thems  W: I got one of these!
J: nO B: HAhaa
M: Haa! *laughs*
B: noOO B: HahaHAhaHA
M: Yey.
W: *dog sounds* J: WHY? B: HaHAHa
W: *more dog sounds*
B: Rusty
B: Oh, fuck. Alright. I'm gon--I'm gonna do that
W: Oh no
M: *laughs*
M: OH NO B: He just--he just plays a card W: WoOoO J: *Sigh*
W: wELL, I hAd A pLAN...toOK it aWAY from ME!
B: Oh, look at this M: FUUCK J: FUCK YOU MAN, FUCK YOU
M: No, No, Yes  W: ALSO GUYS! When you get down to two cards,
W: When you get down to two cards, you have to-- J: NO W: --click "UNO" on the bottom right
W: before you play one or else someone can make you, uh,
W: draw more.
J: Wade, uh, fuck.   B: Oh, you fucking dick
W: Heeheeehee  J: (?) "UNO"! Let's get him!  B: How--wait--
B: wait--how--wait, Wade, how do we make it draw more? I like how you completely didn't tell us that until after--
W: I did! I said--I said you have to click "UNO" before *unintelligible*
B: No, you didn't tell us that in time so we could do it against you--
W: But you couldn't 'cause I clicked "UNO" before I played!
W: You'll see a thing pop up called-- J: He has you by the scrotes here, Bob. B: Sure, sure, mhm... sure.
M: You guys better-- W: *wails* B: I see it, I see you're gone too Wade, no worries--*interrupted by Wade wailing*
M: Haha!  J: Fuck you, Wade.
W: HOOOOH!  M: *laughs*  W: Now BOB'S gonna win!
M: DO THE "UNO" THING! BOB, DO THE "UNO"--DO THE "UNO" THING! :D
B: That...didn't really pan out for me...
B: Don't forget to do the Uno- okay one thing...
M: Nevermind B/J: *Laughs* B: That really did not go my way All: *More laughs*
B: With the Draw 2 that happened there
B: AH! Oh no, why- why was? J: Do it again, buddy
W: NOOOO!
M: Alright, I'll do it again. Hey you wanna trade hands?
W: Woooo!
M: Oh no, wait, skip- skip that guy
M: Sorry, I forgot!
[J, B unintelligble]
M: *wailing* I'm dumb!
J and B: *laughing*
W: Well, at least it's not a zero, that was a skip
M: I'm dumb!
W: *chuckling*
J: That’s the other zero
W: Yeah
M: Wait…
M: Uhh, fffffucker-ducker
J: It’s just you and me, Wade
W: Oh, yeah. We're--what's gonna come down to the wire
B: Ah, fuck
J: I-I really don’t--
B: Oh wHY WHY WHY IS “S” jump in now?! God damn it
W: Shit
J: Yeah, that sucks!
W: You can just click. You don’t hafta...type. You can just click it
B: Yeah, but I-I real--
W: Welp, Jack, it’s down to you and you!
M, J, and B: *laughing*
B: Oh, shit! Hey, I just--
W: EXCEPT IT DOESN’T! *maniacal laughter*
B: Ohhhhhhhhhh
J: Aahhhhh, shitsack
M: Oh, boy
B: Jack, dick him over
M: Dick him! Dick him good!
J: Aww, but I can’t! :(
M: Dick him!
B: Give him the diiiick!
M: Give him the d-oh, ohhhh
J: *groans* Oh, why?
B: *laughing while saying "wow"*
W: *chuckles* Yeah, that hand was terrible!
B: *still laughing* Wow!
M: Ohhh, no
J: I feel I just got, like…fucked in the a-
B: *laughing*
B: Fucking crap
B: Well, Wade’s gonna get down to the one-thingy
W: Oh, god
W: NOOOO!!!
B: *laughing* Yaaaaay!
M: *hopeful, then disappointed noises*
J: Yeah…[unintelligible]…right, either
W: Oh, thank god
J: Shitty, shitty titties
B: *laughing* Yeah, you still don’t have any reds
W: *laughing*
B: *gasp* Ah, fuck!
M: Habooski!
J: *laughing*
W: GREEN?!
J: FUCK!
B: thank y-
B: thank you very much, my friend
J: I messed up- I messed up my d--
W, M, and B (at varying volume and levels of disbelief): UNO!
M: Uno!
W (high pitched): Hey!
B: Oh, and you jumped right in
B: I love it--*interrupted by Mark and Wade noises*
J (with weird accent): I love it, I love it!
M: Bob might win, Bob might win
M: Unless…(B: You can do it!)…I RANdomly pick the color he doesn’t have
W: Oh
B: You can do it, buddy!
M: *consideration noise* BLIP!
W: Three out of four chance (B: You can do it!) of not screwing this up!
B: YEEAAAAHHHHH!!!
M: NOOOOOOO!!!
B: Yeahhhhh! Hahaha
M: No!
J: You motherfucker, Mark!
B: Whoooo!!!
M: Awwww >_<
J: Ah, man :/
M: I had a chance, guys. I had a chance…
B: Yeah! You all have zero! Look who has 122
M: I didn’t have a chance, guys, I had-I didn't have a chance
J: That was really fun!
M: That was…ludicrously fun
M: Why was that so fun?
B: That was super fun, yeah
W: I told you!
B: We doing it again?
J: Imma play like a billion more rounds of this :D
W: We can stop whenever you guys want to, but we're starting a new match
W: Unless you guys want to
M: Yeah
B: Wai-heh-I’ll do another one
M: Yeah, I’d do another one. I’ll do another one.
W: (faintly) Alright (impatiently) Well, let’s play!
J: [unintelligible]...like ten more
M: Okay
B: Let’s play (W: YELLOW!) who wants to be an Uno
W: Aww that's just rude >:(
M: Yeah I know it's rude because fuck you! >:)
B: Wow fucking hardcore
M: That's why it's rude
B: That was fucking hardcore
M: Yeah >:)
M: I'm playing this one to....fuuuuuck youuuu
*everyone starts laughing at Mark*
M: Fuck you
J: Don’t play it to fuck me!
W: Bob and I are being nice to each other to-OH NO!
*Mark, Bob and Jack laughing*
M: Ay, Bob (B: Oh no), I’d like to think I picked your color at the end there
*Wade groans*
M: Because—
B: Yeah, I appreciate that
M: Because I wanted you to win, and also: fUCK YOU!
*Wade laughing*
B: I really-I really appreciate that, Mark
M: Ah, fuck you!
*Wade and Jack dying*
*Bob and Jack laughing*
M: Jesus, I wanna play at some point
W: Wow!
*Bob still laughing*
*Bob still laughing his amazing laugh*
W: Whew, doggie
M: Ugh, you want my hand? You want my hand?
B: Ah, shit. It’s okay Wade
W: Ah, no, it’s okay
B: There’s a fatal--
B: There’s a fatal flaw with that hand, Wade
W: I see it, I see it right now
*Mark and Bob laughing*
W: Ohhh nooo…
B: [unintelligible]..to move one, allllllllllright, well, whatever. You know what?
W: No! …y-you want Jack’s!
B: Ya know-ya know what?
B: You know what?
J: Yes
M: Bob, take mine
M: You want mine?
B: I think-I think we’re just gonna play the long game here
M: Cool
W: Wow!
M: Yeah, mine was actually a pretty decent hand
W: [unintelligible]…trade
B: Oh, wow, yeah. Wade, prepare to get fucked if this gets reversed *laughing*
W: Oh, no! We’re not gonna do that
B: I think we should. I think we should reverse it. I think we should reverse it
W: No, we should not
*Mark chuckling*
*Jack chuckling*
*Wade making pig noises?* *Mark mocking Wade*
B: I think that'd be-I think that'd be fun. I think we should try that.
W: There we go
J: Ahhh- oh no, I couldn’t
M: Blegh!
B: How bout that-how bout that color?
M: *inhale* Ehhhh…nope!
J: Well, why, Bob?
M: Nope
M: Oh, wait, there we go. Yeah, yeahyeahyeahyeah
B:*chuckling* My-
B: My hand was such a piece of shit
W (high pitched): Whooo! Skipped ya!
J: Ah, fuck!
B: Ah, well geez
B: Hey, wook! (Bob, really?)
B: Now *I* can reverse it!
W: Oh yeah?
M: Hey wook! Wook! (“Wook”? Really, Mark?)
M: Wha-wh— (W: Now *I* can reverse it! *laughing*) No, I fucking was-I pressed the god damn button!
*Jack chuckles*
M: I pressed it! Fuck you! I pressed it!
B: You-you do it, Mark. You do it, Mark
M: No, I can’t do it. (B: You got it, buddy) I fucking pressed it before that.
B: Oh, okay
W: Oh my god
M: Fuckin’ you, and fuck you…ffffuck you
*everyone except Mark laughing*
W: I’m just spitting all over because I’m laughing stupidly
*Bob still laughing*
M: Fuck you
B: “Fuckin’ you, and fuck you…fuck you”
J: I also like when somebody has a huge hand. It just looks like "Oooooooooooo-nooo"!
*Mark and Bob laughing*
B: Oh, for god's sakes
J: Shitty titties
W: Better challenge it
B: Ahhhhh... (M: Challenge it) naw, naw, I got a better idea (M: Do it)
W: Oh, boy
J: ...you’re gonna lose instead *cute chuckle*
M: Huuhbooski
B: I got a better idea. I got a better idea
W: Oh?
M: That-- (J: Ahhhh!)
B: Thank you, Mark
W: NO!
W: NO! NO! NO! NO!
M: Fuck ‘im! Fuck ‘im! Fuck ‘im! Fuck ‘im over!
B: I love you!
B: Mark, you are the best, Mark. I love you!
M: Fuck ‘im over! Fuck him
*Wade whining throughout*
J: Oh, that works
*Mark and Jack laughing*
B: You are the best, Mark. I so love you!
W: OH GOD, STOP [unintelligible] stack like that
*Wade chuckling*
J (pained): Ohhhhhhhh!
B (while laughing): Wow!
*Mark and Wade chuckling*
W (disappointed): Ohhh
M: Heeeeyyyyyy!!
B: Oh, criminies
J: Come on! Whatchu got?
M: Hey, wai…
M: Wh-watch this!
W: Oh
M: Fuck
*everyone laughing at Mark*
M (through laughter): Ahhhh, no
W:...so many cards
*Bob and Jack still laughing*
B: I’m not even in last, it’s amazing
*everyone else still chuckling*
B: I’ll just play a regular one
*everyone else still winding down*
M: I still don’t understand how challenging works, so I’m just-"A"!
M: Got it
B: I keep fucking missing (W: Oh, wow!) the jump in opportunities. This is bullshit
J: Yeah, same
W: Here ya go
J: Or I-or I hit the wrong thing
B: Yeah, no, or I, uh, hit the wrong button
W: [unintelligible] you don’t have to (hit?) them, just click on the card you want to jump in
B: I don’t aim-I don’t click that accurately!
W: Oh
M: Uhhhhhh…bubububububu
J: *chicken sounds?*
M: This (W: My eyes are watering from laughing so hard) “D”, yeah
W: What?!
J: Dayum
J: Dayum!
M, J and W: Dayum!!
B: Dayum, boi
M: Damn, Jeffa (?)
W: Reeeeeeddddd! :D
J: Aww, really?
*Bob laughing*
J: You gonna- you’re gonna suck my ass like that, Wade?
*everyone except Jack laughing*
B: Oh, man
M: Uhhh, boiiiiii
W: Oh my god
M: What happened to normal Uno?
B: Uhhhh…
M: Normal...
M:...everyday, standard, Uno?
B: Normal…(M: normal) (J: regular) normal, regular type Uno?
J: Normal, "don't-stab-your-friends" Uno
M: Yeah, you know, that type of Uno
M: You remember that? The-the good old days?
B: Fuck! What the fuck button is “D”?! God damn it!
*Mark and Wade chuckling*
B: Fuckin’ hate the jump in thing
M (mockingly): Uh, I dunno-I dunno what the fuck button is “D”
W (softly): Oh, god
*Jack chuckles*
B: I like...red
W: Oh, no
J: No one else does
W: SHIIIIIT!!!
M: Uh oh
*Bob laughs*
B: Oh, come on! (J: Yeah!!) Come on… really? (J: Fuck!)
M: You coulda-you could drawn more cards
W: *groans*
*everyone but Jack laughs*
J: Yeah, don’t laugh so hard at me
M: Hey! What the fuck!
*Wade and Bob continue laughing*
*Bob dying of laughter*
J: He laughed at meeee :(
M: Well, everyone was laughing! Why me?!
*Bob and Wade laughing but winding down*
M: Everyone was laughing!
J: It’s all I could play!!
*Jack and Mark giggling*
W: Oh my god
J: ALL I had, man!
B: Oh, no, come one. Yeah, okay. Here you go, Jack
*Mark laughing*
B: Here you go, Jack
W: WHHHYYYYY?!?!
M: Wait! No, here we go!
J: FUCK!!!!
W: NOOOOO!
B: *laughing*
M: Ha, fuck you, Bob!
M: Fuck you, Bob!
J: I HAD THAT!!!
B: *still laughing*
M: Go, Wade!
J: That was one of the ones I had!
M: Wade, go!
W: Alright! I’ll make it red
B (softly): No…
M: Why red, Wade?! (J: Oh, fuck my ass!) I gave you a chance, you make it red?!
W: *laughing*
M: Fuck you!
*Wade and Bob laughing*
J: Fuck, me
*Bob and Wade dying of laughter*
J: Dickhole
M: *sigh*
B: Oh, why? Why, though?
W: *laughing*
W: Oh, it's my turn, again. Yay!
M: Ah, boy...
B (silly accent): Uh... I like blue
M (same silly accent): I like blue
W: I'm like dying over here, I'm laughing so hard
J: [unintelligble] ...colors
M: Hoop! BOOOOMM!!
J: [unintelligble]...like
W: NOOOOOOOO!!!!
M: Yep! That's how this goes, boys
*Everyone else talking over each other*
J: That works alright
B: Oh my god, this hand is horrible!
W: Yeah, this is quite unacceptable that we created
M and J: *chuckling*
B: It's fucking trash
W: *sigh*
B: Ugh...well, shit, anyway, whatever...
J: *giggling*
B: Yeah, play that shit. Who cares?
J: Uh!
J: Yesss
M: *groans in frustration*
J: Play that funky music, white boy!
J: No...(*others begin chuckling*) not that one!
M (laughing): Not that funky music!
W: Oh no!
W: No-ho! Bob!
M: *chuckling*
*Bob laughing evilly*
W: aHHA YOU HAD TWO SEVENS
B: oH wait it was your turn again how was it-
B: how was it your turn again
W: (while laughing) I don't know, oh its ok-
B: Why did that happen I don't-
W: its ok I jumped in with a seven
B: oH ok fuck
W: Yeah
M: Fuck, I thought I was jumping in, I just played a normal card guys
(all laughing)
W: no, nO NO!
J: Yeah! Doin' it!
(Mark and Bob laughing)
J: Now your cards say unoooooo
B&J: (old lady voice) OH NOOO
M: (deep sigh)
B: Oh hey
J&M: awww
B: I got one of these guys
M: Pick a good colour Bob
B: This one
J: D'aw
M: Thats alright I'll accept that, here Bob go again, go again, go again Bob
J: That, thats a shit one
B: oH REALLY?!?!?! YAY
M: Yeah Bob, I'm here to help you bOb
W: NOO!
B: Help me wiiiin
M: I dID
J: fuuUUCK